6 44 here on a wednesday morning you
know boys town has a long history here
in southern nevada and in the last year
helped more than 6 600 local children
struggling to get by now boys town is
hoping you can help get involved john
edsel is the executive director of boys
town good to see you john good to see
you as well glad to be here this morning
so we've talked before about what boys
town does here in the valley uh let's
talk a little bit about now this morning
of just how important how vital boys
town is to teenagers children in las
vegas
yeah so i mean with with as many things
are going on as parents and families are
coming out of the pandemic clark county
school district we've seen a lot of the
challenges that families are are having
some of the behavior issues have been
going on here in the district boyce town
works to improve that
we work with kids specifically to teach
them social skills on how to
get along with each other how to get
along with their teachers how to get
along with administrators and we're
finding that to be more important than
ever right now so we're continuing to
grow we've seen so many unfortunate
discipline issues on campus
students with against students students
against teachers what has clark county
school district asked of boys town to
try and help
yeah so the district has asked us to ask
us to continue to
grow and continue to teach not only the
the kids but we're training
administrators and teachers on less
restrictive practices so ways that they
can continue to praise kids for the good
things that they're doing in the
classroom restorative justice kind of
fits in that restorative justice
absolutely fits into that we want kids
to be able to learn how to get along
with others
so you're talking about boys town going
into more schools around the valley how
many schools in the next school year
will boys town be in yeah so we're in 28
schools right now we're going to grow to
65 schools in this upcoming year so
we've got a lot of positions and a lot
of jobs to fill right now that leads us
to the job fair that's happening uh
today and tomorrow
what are you looking for what can the
community do to fill these positions
what are you looking to fill yeah check
out our website we've got direct care
positions where folks will be working
immediately in the schools elementary
middle and high school level and then
we've also got positions that work in
people's homes where we go and we work
with families
parents grandparents aunts uncles
wherever kids are are living in order to
improve that communication as well and
boys town does such great work here in
the valley and with the need being so
great right now and the expansion of
your work in the district it's good to
see you john and hopefully you can help
out at home as well thank you appreciate
it we have details as well at
8newsnow.com